la vida de rodrigo cambió radicalmente
el día que su esposa carol fue
diagnosticada con cáncer de mama paso de
empleado público a través de una
licencia concentrarse en las tareas del
hogar cuidar a sus hijas y apoyar a su
pareja rodrigo entendió que el estado de
ánimo de karol era clave para su
recuperación
acudieron juntos a talleres de apoyo
emocional y relaciones que de repente se
quiebran y otra que es un apoyo para
poder unirse más todavía y en este caso
para mí fue la segunda en la cual
sentí la necesidad estar ahí presente
todo el tiempo
porque sin saber cómo poder apoyar pero
si quería estar ahí para carol contar
con su esposo su red de amigos y ayuda
profesional ha sido esencial para
sobrellevar lo más duro de la enfermedad
y compartir también los resultados
positivos soy muy importante sea él el
primer apoyo que uno que recibo todos
los días desde que me diagnosticaron
esto fue el ahí estando al lado mío al
pie del cañón o sea los dos pasamos
momentos
íntimos muy malos pero así como malos
también pasa un momento muy bueno amparo
es psicóloga de la corporación yo mujer
a través de internet ayuda a pacientes
de cáncer de mama de toda américa latina
para ella la asistencia psicológica y el
apoyo de la familia es fundamental vivir
un duelo duelo a partir de todas las
pérdidas que se enfrentan ya sea la
pérdida de los cambios físicos no desde
tu pelo cuando realizas quimioterapia o
de tu mamá una parte de tu mamá cuando
eres eres operada no
cambios en tu energía vital no en tus
ganas de hacer cosas incluso en tus
roles operada del pecho y sin una de sus
mamás carol sigue adelante el cáncer
reforzó su relación de pareja ella y
rodrigo aprendieron a transitar unidos
la montaña rusa de emociones y gestionar
mejor los días buenos y muchos malos que
trae consigo el largo proceso de
recuperarse del cáncer de mama